ايمان يا رشود
التلويح الروسي المستمر باستخدام اسلحه
النوويه تكتيكيه في حرب اوكرانيا يرسل
رسائل متعدده داخليا ودوليا
فبحسب تحليلات النشراتها صحف غربيه فان
ورقه السلاح النووي التكتيكيه هي لعبه
خطيره يمارسها الجنرالات الروس لتحقيق
اقصى الصفاده
تاييد الشعبي لما تطلق عليه روسيا الحمله
العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا وخاصه مع
تراجع هذا الدعم منذ بدات عمليات استدعاء
قوات الاحتياط وارسالها لساحات المعارك
ورغم عدم وجود مؤشرات حقيقيه علانيه روسيا
لاستخدام هذا السلاح الا ان يرفع نشرت ان
قاده الروس بحثوا خلال اجتماعاتهم هذا
الخيار وهو ما اثر قلق المسؤولين
الامريكيين
التلويح بورقه السلاح النوويه يرسل ايضا
تهديدات للضغط على اوكرانيا للبدء في
مباحثات دبلوماسيه وتقديم تنازلات وخاصه
مع التغيرات على الارض من تقدم للقوات
الاوكرانيه وتراجع للقوات الروسيه
الرساله الثالثه التي تحملها التهديدات
الروسيه مواجهه لحلف الناتو الدول الغربيه
التي زودت اوكرانيا باطمان من الاسلحه
الحديثه مكانتها من تحقيق تقدم على الارض
التلويح بورقه السلاح النووي قد يكون
كافيا بحسب الصحيفه
لثاني واشنطن وحلفائها في الغرب عن ارسال
المزيد من هذه الاسلحه لاوكرانيا